I'm alone, but a pity I won't be soon In New York City, when I see you.
我独自一人，但遗憾的是，当我见到你时，我不会很快在纽约市。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
Well hello out there, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother where I, Josh Radner, I'm talking to my friend Craig Thomas, who's here right now.
大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何造就你的母亲》的另一集，我，乔什·拉德纳，正在和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯交谈，他现在就在这里。
I'm staring at him, hi Craig.
我盯着他，嗨，克雷格。
I'm right here.
我就在这里。
It's true and Greg co-created a show called how I met your mother with Carter Bays that I start on from 2005 to 2014 we're making our way through each episode.
确实如此，Greg 与 Carter Bays 共同创作了一部名为《我是如何遇见你母亲的》的节目，我从 2005 年开始播放到 2014 年，我们正在逐步完成每一集。
We're deep into the second season Today we're discussing episode what what episode of this is the second season's episode 16 number 16 Sweet 16 this episode is called stuff.
我们正在深入第二季今天我们正在讨论第二季的第 16 集第 16 集甜蜜 16 这一集被称为东西。
It was written by are the great Courtney Kang, Cocoa, Cocoa, Cocoa, Cocoa, all of us here, and Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
它的作者是伟大的考特尼·康、可可、可可、可可、可可，我们在座的所有人，还有亚历克，请告诉我们这一集何时播出。
This aired on February 19th, 2007, and I'm pretty sure if you're listening to this today on the day it dropped, it is February 16th or so.
该节目于 2007 年 2 月 19 日播出，我很确定如果您今天在收听该节目，那一天就是 2 月 16 日左右。
So close.
这么近。
All surrounding right there.
周围的一切都在那里。
Don't worry about it.
别担心。
But yeah, we're almost, we're almost exactly in time.
但是，是的，我们几乎，我们几乎完全准时了。
So we're They're officially 19 years ahead of each episode as they are.
所以我们比他们每集正式提前 19 年。
Almost to the day.
快到这一天了。
That's how we designed them.
这就是我们设计它们的方式。
The minute.
分钟。
Totally.
完全。
It's got a 19 year purpose.
它有一个19年的目标。
Lucky number 19.
幸运数字19。
What a weird number.
多么奇怪的数字啊。
That's round number 19.
这是第 19 轮。
If you met someone in their favorite number was 19, you'd be like, what are you talking about?
如果你遇到某人最喜欢的数字是 19，你会说，你在说什么？
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
Anyway, so this episode, Craig, this is a, we talked about it.
无论如何，所以这一集，克雷格，这是我们讨论过的。
It's a bit of a lighter episode, however, it has a couple of things in it that I think it become like weirdly iconic both for the fans and also I got to say there were a couple things that I had forgotten they were in this episode that were on set hilarity.
这是一个有点轻松的剧集，然而，它有一些东西，我认为它对粉丝来说变得像奇怪的标志性的，而且我不得不说，有几件事我忘记了，它们在这一集中是欢闹的。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
Okay.
好的。
So I think top half fish bottom half humid, like the mermaid question is kind of entered the, the how, how I made your mother lore.
所以我认为鱼的上半部分下半部分潮湿，就像美人鱼的问题一样，我如何让你的母亲知道。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
That's the, we, we bring it back throughout the series.
这就是我们在整个系列中带回来的。
It's a big debate.
这是一场大辩论。
And I gotta say, if you said, you know, gun to head, what is your, what episode was that in?
我得说，如果你说，你知道，枪对着头，那是什么，那是在哪一集？
I'd be like, I have no idea.
我会说，我不知道。
I have no idea.
我不知道。
I remember the bit.
我记得那一点。
I remember the argument.
我记得那个争论。
Well, the weird thing is many seasons later, we did an episode called the mermaid theory.
嗯，奇怪的是很多季之后，我们做了一集叫做美人鱼理论。
That's about something completely different.
这是完全不同的事情。
We have a whole other mermaid thing that has to do with mistaking manatees for being mermaids because it's a bunch of dudes out at sea and on a boat and they're so starved for women that that's the genesis of mermaids.
我们还有另外一个关于美人鱼的事情，它与将海牛误认为是美人鱼有关，因为这是一群在海上和船上的家伙，他们非常渴望女人，这就是美人鱼的起源。
The idea that if you will start to hallucinate if you're sort of lonely and imagine mermaids where there are manatees, that's like many years later in a whole, we were obsessed with mermaids for some reason on the show.
如果你有点孤独，就会开始产生幻觉，想象有海牛的地方有美人鱼，就像很多年后，我们在节目中出于某种原因对美人鱼着迷。
That's what I've discovered.
这就是我发现的。
Would you say that Splash was a formative influence on you and Carter?
您是否认为 Splash 对您和卡特产生了影响？
Apparently, because I'd kept coming up.
显然，因为我一直上来。
Splash is a freaking great movie.
《飞溅》是一部非常棒的电影。
Yeah, that's in there, that's in the, that's in the mix.
是的，就在那里，就在其中，就在混合中。
Yeah.
是的。
So what were your, what were your thoughts when you, when you revisited this episode?
那么，当你重温这一集时，你的想法是什么？
Do you watch all the episodes with Rebecca?
你和丽贝卡一起看所有剧集吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And also sometimes we jump ahead, you and I, when we're, we have to record something out of sequence and she refuses to do it.
有时我们会跳到前面，你和我，当我们跳到前面时，我们必须不按顺序录制一些东西，而她拒绝这样做。
Yeah.
是的。
Cause she's having lunch with my wife and they're complaining about us jumping ahead.
因为她正在和我妻子一起吃午饭，而他们却在抱怨我们超前。
I know.
我知道。
You said Jordana have the same thing and she won't, she refuses to do it.
你说乔丹娜也有同样的事情，但她不会，她拒绝这样做。
She just wants to go sequentially and I respect that.
她只是想按顺序进行，我尊重这一点。
So sometimes I jump ahead to watch one, and then I have to rewatch it when she and I then catch back up to it.
所以有时我会跳到前面看一部，然后当我和她追上来时我必须重新观看。
So there's certain of them that I'm watching twice.
所以有些内容我看了两遍。
But she thought this one was really funny.
但她觉得这件事真的很有趣。
She said, this one's just a joke machine.
她说，这只是一个笑话机器。
That was her take.
这是她的看法。
She's like, this is just a funny little joke machine.
她说，这只是一个有趣的小笑话机器。
And it's true, it's very funny.
这是真的，这非常有趣。
I think it's a really funny episode, a lot of great moments, but it's light and it's silly, a lot of stupid stuff.
我认为这是一个非常有趣的插曲，有很多精彩的时刻，但它很轻松而且很愚蠢，有很多愚蠢的东西。
I love the series arc thing of continuing to slap that.
我喜欢继续打那个系列的弧线。
I love the bravado of, when I was rewatching it, I was thinking, oh, well, I remember it ends with slap number two, when Neil's dressed as a crazy tin man like robot.
我喜欢虚张声势，当我重看它时，我在想，哦，好吧，我记得它以第二巴掌结束，当时尼尔打扮成一个像机器人一样疯狂的铁皮人。
I remember that image so well on how funny it was, but I thought, oh, we must remind the viewer about the slap that, right?
我清楚地记得那张图片，它有多么有趣，但我想，哦，我们必须提醒观众那一巴掌，对吧？
There's many episodes between this episode, you know, when we set that up in this Robin Sparkles episode.
你知道，当我们在罗宾·斯帕克斯这一集里设置这一集时，这一集之间有很多集。
And the whole episode I'm watching last night going, when are we gonna set that up?
我昨晚正在看整集，我们什么时候安排呢？
When are we gonna remind the viewer?
我们什么时候提醒观众？
And then I remembered the bravado of, we just didn't say a fucking word.
然后我想起了我们的虚张声势，我们只是他妈的一句话也没说。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
And at the very end, he just gets the shit slapped out and Marshall just goes, that's two.
最后，他只是被打了一顿，马歇尔就走了，那就是两个。
And if you missed that other episode, three months earlier, you're like, what the fuck just happened?
如果你错过了三个月前的另一集，你会想，刚刚到底发生了什么？
But there's, I gotta say, I kind of respected this one.
但我得说，我有点尊重这一点。
I know, the literal thing.
我知道，字面上的意思。
And the medical thing.
还有医疗方面的事情。
The literal thing.
字面上的东西。
We didn't say that.
我们没这么说。
Yeah, it's funny also in the kind of moral universe of how I met your mother.
是的，在我遇见你母亲的道德世界中也很有趣。
Like Barney deserved to be slapped right there.
就像巴尼应该在那里被打一巴掌一样。
I think it's slapped.
我觉得是被打了
He absolutely merited that slap.
那一巴掌他绝对活该。
What else in this episode struck you?
这一集还有什么让你印象深刻的吗？
Excuse the pun.
请原谅双关语。
My sense memories of watching the episode where I remember how satisfying it was.
我对观看这一集的感觉记忆是多么令人满意。
Barney was such a dick when he got the shit sucked out.
巴尼被吸出来的时候真是个混蛋。
I'm kneeled in an amazing fall.
我在一次惊人的跌倒中跪下。
He had another great meal, physical comedy moment.
他又吃了一顿美餐，肢体喜剧时刻。
How satisfying that was.
那是多么满足啊。
But I remember the other visceral thing, but I remember you talking about it at the time and reminding me over the years and kind of hating me slash Carter slash whoever wrote it for, Courtney Kang, I guess, to, you said, getting licked on the face by various dog actors was really not a high point for you.
但我记得另一件发自内心的事情，但我记得你当时谈论它，并提醒我多年来，有点讨厌我斜线卡特斜线无论是谁写的，考特尼·康，我想，你说，被各种狗演员舔脸对你来说真的不是一个高潮。
Oh yes, that was the worst, that was one of the worst things that happened to me on how I met your mother was getting licked on the face.
哦，是的，那是最糟糕的，这是我遇到你母亲时发生在我身上的最糟糕的事情之一，那就是脸被舔了。
I remember you saying at the time, you came up to me after the take.
我记得你当时说，拍摄结束后你来找我。
And because I was on set, I think for that one, you said to me, my face still smells like drying saliva right now, Craig.
因为我在片场，我想对于那个，你对我说，我的脸现在仍然闻起来像干燥的唾液，克雷格。
You guys did this to me and I'm not, I won't soon forget it.
你们对我做了这样的事，但我没有，我不会很快忘记。
You were really unhappy with that, and I am sorry.
你对此真的很不满意，我很抱歉。
I was really unhappy, yeah.
我真的很不高兴，是的。
There was no way for me to kind of like, stiff up or lip that, that.
我没有办法喜欢、僵硬或用嘴唇说那个、那个。
Like, I was really, I really hated it.
就像，我真的，我真的很讨厌它。
Upper lip was getting licked by a strange man.
上唇被一个陌生男人舔了舔。
And it's also funny, like, one of the challenges we had, and I had to reveal this to you right after I was cast, was I'm allergic to dogs.
这也很有趣，就像我们面临的挑战之一，我在选角后必须立即向你们透露这一点，那就是我对狗过敏。
I mean, I am very public about, I have a labradoodle now named Nelson, who has my whole heart, and he doesn't make me sneeze, is hypoallergenic, but my whole life have been very allergic to dogs.
我的意思是，我非常公开地说，我有一只拉布拉多犬，现在名叫尼尔森，它全心全意地爱着我，它不会让我打喷嚏，它是低过敏性的，但我一生都对狗非常过敏。
And then I get cat, it was basically like me getting cast on a Western.
然后我就得到了猫，这基本上就像我在西部片中扮演角色一样。
You're like, you ever had a horse?
你说，你养过马吗？
And I'm like, I can't do it.
我想，我做不到。
But you know, Robin had these five dogs.
但你知道，罗宾有这五只狗。
And I was like, I'm also allergic, I realized to strange men, day players coming in and licking me on the face.
我当时想，我也过敏，我意识到陌生的男人，白天的球员进来舔我的脸。
I didn't know that that also.
我也不知道那个。
It's a rare allergy test.
这是一项罕见的过敏测试。
They can test for it now.
他们现在可以进行测试。
Your skin will just blow up.
你的皮肤会爆炸。
I'm glad we're raising awareness for it because it is a real thing.
我很高兴我们提高了人们对它的认识，因为它是真实存在的。
Well, it's a great bit of the, so the gist of this episode, why don't you tell us the kind of inciting idea for this?
嗯，这是一个很棒的部分，所以这集的要点，你为什么不告诉我们这个的煽动性想法呢？
We didn't even do this.
我们甚至没有这样做。
Right, we didn't even do our little, oh yeah.
是的，我们甚至没有尽自己的绵薄之力，哦，是的。
I mean, the philosophical symposium of this episode, I do love a good, this falls under the Hennium category of like philosophical debate, go some episodes, a little mysteries, this one is just a symposium on, when you're in a new relationship, the way Ted and Robin are in this episode.
我的意思是，这一集的哲学研讨会，我确实很喜欢，这属于像哲学辩论这样的Hennium类别，去一些剧集，有点神秘，这只是一场研讨会，当你处于一段新的关系中时，泰德和罗宾在这一集中的方式。
Are you to pretend that you've never once been with another person before this person?
你要假装在这个人之前你从来没有和另一个人在一起过吗？
Are you supposed to act like that's the universe only revolves around this one person?
难道你就该表现得好像宇宙只围着这个人转吗？
Or do you acknowledge all the other human beings that you had feelings for and you dated and all that's why it's called stuff.
或者你是否承认所有其他你有感情和约会过的人，这就是为什么它被称为东西。
It's about the things, the things we keep from previous relationships.
这是关于那些我们从以前的关系中保留下来的事情。
And I really love the twist in this episode that when we think it's all about the stuff The Ted has been given by various women, and then it turns out Robin has these living, breathing things that represent her previous relationships.
我真的很喜欢这一集中的转折，当我们认为这一切都是关于泰德被不同的女人给予的东西时，结果罗宾拥有这些活生生的、会呼吸的东西，这些东西代表了她以前的关系。
They're the boyfriends that she got dogs with, which is also insane, by the way.
他们是她养狗的男朋友，顺便说一句，这也很疯狂。
We didn't spend enough time in the episode being like, how many dogs, how many, how many date these guys that you got dogs with?
我们没有花足够的时间在这一集中，比如，有多少只狗，有多少，有多少与你养狗的人约会？
It feels pathological, like every boyfriend there's a dog that's involved.
这感觉很病态，就像每个男朋友都有一只狗一样。
It does, we skipped over that really huge question, I guess, can we maybe?
确实如此，我们跳过了这个非常大的问题，我想，我们可以吗？
I also think there's something funny about, they keep going back to the booth and back to the gang.
我还认为有一些有趣的事情，他们不断地回到摊位，回到团伙。
It feels like they're visiting like the oracle of Delphi or something where they're just like we're like we have another riddle We have another question.
感觉就像他们正在访问德尔斐的神谕或其他东西，就像我们有另一个谜语一样，我们还有另一个问题。
You have to help us solve this Yeah, totally and I love that.
你必须帮助我们解决这个问题 是的，完全如此，我喜欢这一点。
I mean that that's kind of a long-running tradition of him and where it's like we're gonna put it to the group Yeah, they're they're having huge arguments between the two of them and they say the only way to solve this is the group And there's something kind of nice about that the high the hive mind of the five together They'll they'll get some and you know you can expect like Lily's gonna kind of answer one way Barney's gonna answer another way Even though this episode is a joke machine, the underlying kind of philosophical question that you just laid out is a really deep and serious question that I think anyone who's dated more than two people has had to go on your face.
我的意思是，这是他长期以来的传统，就像我们要把它放到小组里一样，是的，他们两个之间有很大的争论，他们说解决这个问题的唯一方法是小组，五个人在一起的高蜂巢思维有一些很好的东西，他们会得到一些，你知道你可以期待莉莉会以一种方式回答巴尼会以另一种方式回答即使这一集是一个笑话机器，你刚才提出的潜在哲学问题是一个非常深刻而严肃的问题，我认为任何约会过两个以上的人的人都必须面对你的问题。
Yeah, and Marshall and Lily are the exception.
是的，马歇尔和莉莉是例外。
Yeah, they're the exception because they got together so young.
是的，他们是例外，因为他们很年轻就在一起了。
But if you get together and you have some life under your belt, you also have some history and you have some incredible memories and vacations and mementos and things that are going to you, they've probably taken their kind of rightful place in your, you know, credenza of memories and they're not like actively provoking you and maybe you like that throw pillow or whatever, but to the newish boyfriend or girlfriend, they can be very provocative because it feels like, well, you're holding on to a piece of them, you haven't let that go.
但如果你们聚在一起，你们有过一些生活，你们也有一些历史，你们有一些令人难以置信的回忆、假期、纪念品和那些属于你们的东西，它们可能已经在你们的记忆书柜中占据了应有的位置，它们不像主动挑衅你，也许你喜欢那个抱枕或其他什么，但对于新的男朋友或女朋友来说，它们可能非常挑衅，因为感觉就像，嗯，你抓住了其中的一部分，你还没有放开它。
Like, how significant was this for you if you still have these pieces and mementos around the apartment.
就像，如果你的公寓周围还保留着这些物品和纪念品，这对你来说有多重要。
Yeah, and it's part of your life story before you met that person, but it's also fair for that person to be a little bit weary of it, maybe.
是的，这是你遇到那个人之前生活故事的一部分，但也许那个人对此有点厌倦也是公平的。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I don't know.
是的，我不知道。
I think it's a good philosophical debate.
我认为这是一场很好的哲学辩论。
I don't know that there's a right or wrong answer to it, but it's like, it's very human.
我不知道这个问题的答案是对是错，但它很人性化。
I think everybody, even Marshall and Lily, there's Marshall's earlier in this season was really triggered at the idea that scooter had gotten a little bit further around the bases with Lilly, than he thought.
我想每个人，甚至马歇尔和莉莉，马歇尔在本赛季早些时候都被这样的想法所触发，即滑板车与莉莉一起在基地上取得了比他想象的更远的想法。
Even in that situation, it's like, they've basically only been with each other, but there's still that, and I think it's just, it's very real, it's very real.
即使在那种情况下，他们基本上只是在一起，但仍然存在，我认为这就是，它非常真实，非常真实。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了送你去纽约。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
There's a kind of, I don't know, there's a kind of like greed component to love.
我不知道，爱有一种贪婪的成分。
Like I wanna be the only one you've ever felt this way about.
就像我想成为你唯一一个有过这种感觉的人。
I wanna be the only one, you know?
我想成为唯一的一个，你知道吗？
I will say that the recurring visual bit that I thought Pam and the team did such a great job with is like the objects and Ted's apartment turning into these women who then taught Robin and then the dogs turning into these ex-boyfriends.
我想说的是，我认为帕姆和团队做得非常出色的反复出现的视觉效果就像物体和特德的公寓变成了这些女人，然后她们教罗宾，然后狗变成了这些前男友。
It did, that was one of the things where I was like, You cannot do that at a live taping in one night like that is like that's proper filmmaking.
确实如此，这就是我当时想的事情之一，你不能在一个晚上的现场录音中做到这一点，就像那是正确的电影制作一样。
It reminded me like when when the objects were morphing into the women that did it dated Jordan and I like we're always struggling like what movies or TV shows to watch because our taste somewhat overlap sometimes but also often veer.
这让我想起了当物体变成与乔丹约会的女人时，我喜欢我们总是在纠结要看什么电影或电视节目，因为我们的品味有时有些重叠，但也经常发生变化。
But for some reason the other night, we watched it over two nights and I had never seen it and I just want to say I enjoyed every frame of it.
但那天晚上出于某种原因，我们看了两个晚上，我从来没有看过它，我只想说我喜欢它的每一帧。
We watched Terminator 2.
我们看了《终结者2》。
Oh fuck yeah.
哦他妈的是的。
Wait, had you never seen Terminator 2?
等等，你没看过终结者2吗？
Terminator 2, don't you guys don't yell at me.
终结者2，你们别骂我了。
I'm saying I was watching it.
我说的是我在看。
It's one of Jordana's favorite movies.
这是乔丹娜最喜欢的电影之一。
She said her name.
她说出了她的名字。
Jordana, yes Jordana.
乔丹娜，是的乔丹娜。
It's one of my favorite movies.
这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
Yeah, I love that movie.
是的，我喜欢那部电影。
I was watching it.
我正在看它。
And first of all, I want to say I was watching it.
首先，我想说我正在观看它。
and I was like, is James Cameron actually maybe the best director frame for frame of like, the action sequences that are so, it's unbelievable that movie that like got made in what 92 or something, like, 91?
我当时想，詹姆斯·卡梅隆实际上可能是最好的导演框架，动作序列是如此，令人难以置信的是，像这样的电影是在92年或类似的91年制作的？
Yeah, I think 92, 91, 91, but I referenced it in my novel, Josh, I don't know if you remember, there's a moment where Rob and my novel is having a hard day and his wife Paige comes home and finds him watching Terminator 2 because she says that's his, that's his movie.
是的，我想是 92、91、91，但我在我的小说中提到过，乔什，我不知道你是否还记得，有那么一刻，罗布和我的小说度过了艰难的一天，他的妻子佩奇回家发现他在看《终结者 2》，因为她说那是他的，那是他的电影。
He watches when he's having a hard day because men think that when they're having a bad day, the stakes are the apocalypse, like that's how male brains work.
当他度过艰难的一天时，他会观察，因为男人认为，当他们度过糟糕的一天时，风险就是世界末日，就像男性大脑的工作方式一样。
So they need to watch an apocalypse to help them feel.
所以他们需要观看末日来帮助他们感受。
But I really, and that's what I really do.
但我真的，这就是我真正所做的。
I really watch a movie all the time.
我真的一直在看电影。
It feels as good as any, you could stack that movie up against any classic Hollywood classic.
感觉和任何一部都一样好，你可以将这部电影与任何经典的好莱坞经典相媲美。
And it's like frame for frame, it is, I was never bored.
就像一帧一帧一样，我从不感到无聊。
It's like a fully explored and executed universe.
这就像一个经过充分探索和执行的宇宙。
I really thought it was like a masterpiece.
我真的认为这就像一部杰作。
It's like a perfect piece of writing, too.
这也就像一篇完美的文章。
It's perfectly constructed that story, but what it reminded me of, the way that the pillow morphs into a woman reminded me of the liquid metal, the guy, the scarier robot, I so forgot what we were talking about, but I thought we all had a gummy right at the beginning.
这个故事的结构很完美，但它让我想起了什么，枕头变成女人的方式让我想起了液态金属、那个家伙、那个更可怕的机器人，我忘了我们在说什么，但我以为我们一开始都有口香糖。
No, we're doing a podcast about terminators here.
不，我们正在做一个关于终结者的播客。
Are we recording this?
我们正在记录这个吗？
It's our relaunch podcast of terminator, we do it, but it reminded me of the liquid metal, how he could just reconstitute himself.
这是我们重新推出的《终结者》播客，我们这样做了，但这让我想起了液态金属，他如何能够重建自己。
I bet we gave that as a mnemonic to the effect house.
我敢打赌我们把它作为效果屋的助记符。
We said we wanted to be Terminator 2.
我们说过我们想成为《终结者2》。
It allowed us to at least do a tight 90 seconds on the glories of Terminator 2.
它让我们至少能在 90 秒的时间里尽情享受《终结者 2》的辉煌。
It's so good.
太好了。
Yeah, I'm so glad I know it now, and my dad too is also like, yeah, it's one of the best movies.
是的，我很高兴我现在知道了，我爸爸也觉得，是的，这是最好的电影之一。
It's also like the rare Godfather 2, an amazingly good sequel that's maybe as good or better than the first one.
它也像罕见的《教父 2》一样，是一部非常出色的续集，可能与第一部一样好，甚至更好。
It just doesn't happen that up.
它只是不会发生那样的事情。
But we were trying, both of them were on Netflix and we were trying to decide if we watched Terminator 1 or Terminator 2 and she says, we'll watch the preview for Terminator 1.
但我们一直在尝试，这两部影片都在 Netflix 上播放，我们试图决定是看《终结者 1》还是《终结者 2》，她说，我们会看《终结者 1》的预览。
I watched the preview and I was like, okay, I understand what happened in Terminator 1.
我看了预告片，心想，好吧，我明白《终结者 1》中发生的事情了。
It's also great.
这也很棒。
It's also great and worth going back, but Terminator 2 is probably better.
它也很棒，值得回顾，但《终结者 2》可能更好。
I know it's great, but I'm also like, I'm ready now to watch Terminator 2.
我知道这很棒，但我也想，我现在准备好观看《终结者 2》了。
Yeah, Terminator 2 is better.
是的，终结者2更好。
So you have maybe made the right call.
所以你可能做出了正确的决定。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, it's amazing.
哦，太棒了。
But yes, that effect is very liquidy.
但是，是的，这种效应非常具有流动性。
the way in those, they sort of like the little British phone was sort of a liquid lease expands into this human.
在这些方面，它们有点像英国的小电话，是一种流动租赁扩展到人类身上。
Yeah, I like that effect.
是的，我喜欢这种效果。
It's very similar.
非常相似。
And that was the other kind of great effect and we can talk later about this, but the sped up argument between Robin and Ted at the end that ends in them somehow limping their way across the finish line with the revelation that they should move in together.
这是另一种巨大的效果，我们可以稍后再讨论，但是最后罗宾和泰德之间的争论加速，最终导致他们以某种方式一瘸一拐地冲过终点线，并发现他们应该一起住。
It is not our first fast forwarded argument in series.
这不是我们系列中第一个快进的论点。
in season two, we've maybe had four or five of them.
在第二季中，我们可能有四五个。
We love that device.
我们喜欢那个设备。
You can't do that.
你不能那样做。
It's a good bit.
这是一个很好的一点。
It's a live audience.
这是现场观众。
Yeah.
是的。
And by the way, I was trying to remember, I think you and Carter or Courtney wrote us some dialogue, or did you just say fight?
顺便说一句，我试图记住，我想你和卡特或考特尼给我们写了一些对话，或者你只是说打架？
Do you remember?
你是否记得？
I think we wrote, I think Courtney probably wrote up a map of like, let's cover these bases and so it's to help it last long enough, but I bet you guys improved around whatever a little map was.
我想我们写了，我想考特尼可能写了一张类似的地图，让我们覆盖这些基地，这样可以帮助它持续足够长的时间，但我敢打赌你们会围绕一张小地图进行改进。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It'd be fun to ask Kobe if she remembers, but I think we did have, I think at that point, we knew the terrain of both our relationship and the central argument that we probably just got unleashed.
问科比是否还记得会很有趣，但我认为我们确实记得，我认为在那时，我们知道我们关系的范围以及我们可能刚刚释放的中心论点。
And I think my memory is we were going crazy, we were doing it and she was, Pam was kind of sending us around the room so she could get a variety of things.
我想我的记忆是我们快要疯了，我们正在这样做，而她，帕姆有点带我们在房间里转，这样她就可以得到各种各样的东西。
I wonder how long you did it for, how long it was.
我想知道你做了多久，做了多久。
But I do, I think I remember at the end, Pam called Cut and I think the crew applauded.
但我记得，我想我记得最后，帕姆给剪辑打了电话，我想工作人员鼓掌了。
Like I think the crew was like into it.
我认为工作人员很喜欢它。
Like it was a Eugene O'Neill.
就像是尤金·奥尼尔一样。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, like we really, but we really, even in the fast forward, you can see that we were in it.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，就像我们真的一样，但我们真的，即使在快进中，你也可以看到我们身处其中。
We were really.
我们真的是。
You were having a fight and it was so well done that the twist that they make this decision to move in together plays like a great surprise because like how the fuck did we get there?
你们正在吵架，而且做得太好了，以至于他们做出搬到一起的决定就像一个巨大的惊喜，因为就像我们他妈的怎么到那里的？
It's great, I almost forgot.
太棒了，我差点忘了。
And that is the sort of like emotional ballast of this episode.
这就是这一集的情感镇流器。
Something important happens at the end of this episode that sets up a whole new condition that we explore for the rest of season two.
在这一集的结尾发生了一些重要的事情，它建立了一个全新的条件，我们将在第二季的剩余部分中探索这一点。
So that you need that at the end of this episode.
所以你在本集结束时需要它。
What strikes me as we're talking that the A story between Ted and Robin is what do you owe your partner vis-a-vis your past?
当我们谈论泰德和罗宾之间的故事时，令我印象深刻的是，相对于你的过去，你欠你的伴侣什么？
Yes.
是的。
And the B story is actually about friendship.
而B的故事其实是关于友谊的。
What do you owe your friends?
你欠朋友什么？
Yeah, I like that.
是的，我喜欢这样。
When they ask you to kind of sit through something somewhat unbearable.
当他们要求你坐下来经历一些令人难以忍受的事情时。
To me that makes this a more structurally sound episode than like columns.
对我来说，这使得这一集在结构上比类似的专栏更加合理。
Remember we were talking about that with some columns a few episodes earlier where it was like the A story and the B story were very separate and they didn't really dove to You could have dropped the B story into any other episode.
请记住，我们在前几集的一些专栏中讨论过这一点，就像 A 故事和 B 故事非常独立，他们并没有真正投入到你可以将 B 故事放入任何其他剧集中。
And that is not us playing or at strength.
这不是我们在玩或在发挥力量。
You see us still, we're still learning in season two.
你仍然看到我们，我们仍在第二季学习。
What are our superpowers?
我们的超能力是什么？
What are our things that are harder?
我们的哪些事情比较难？
Separate A, B story is not good on how much mother.
分开A、B的故事对妈妈来说并不好。
This flirts with being that, but the emotional kind of overlap of what do you owe partner?
这与那样调情，但是你欠伴侣什么的情感重叠？
What do you owe a friend?
你欠朋友什么？
The whole episode is this kind of philosophical symposium based on what do you owe these people you love.
整集就是一场基于你欠这些你爱的人什么的哲学研讨会。
And also the honesty versus the kind of obfuscation piece.
还有诚实与混淆的部分。
Do I act like I've never once dated anybody else?
我表现得好像我从来没有和其他人约会过吗？
Do I act like my friends play as great, even when it's totally horrible to sit through?
我是否表现得像我的朋友们玩得一样好，即使坐着玩是非常可怕的？
What do we owe each other honesty and transparency?
我们对彼此的诚实和透明度有什么义务？
Or do we owe each other lies and glazing things over?
或者我们是否欠彼此谎言和粉饰？
I don't know.
我不知道。
There's a very famous couple's therapist named Terry Reel, Terence Reel, and he writes great books.
有一位非常著名的夫妻治疗师，名叫特里·里尔（Terry Reel），特伦斯·里尔（Terence Reel），他写了很棒的书。
But yeah, I've heard him say this a number of times interviews, that one of the worst things you can engage in in a partnership is what he calls unbridled self-expression.
但是，是的，我在采访中多次听到他说过这样的话，在合作伙伴关系中你可以做的最糟糕的事情之一就是他所说的无节制的自我表达。
Like just saying, like, I'm just being honest, but you're also being cruel.
就像只是说，就像，我只是诚实，但你也很残忍。
You're using no discernment, you're using no softening of tone, you're in total opposition, and you're just trying to take them out at the kneecaps.
你没有使用洞察力，你没有使用软化的语气，你完全反对，你只是想把他们的膝盖拿掉。
There's no, it's like fighting unfairly.
没有，这就像不公平的战斗。
Right?
正确的？
Yeah.
是的。
And Barney, at least from a friend perspective, is a fan of unbridled self-expression.
而巴尼，至少从朋友的角度来看，是无拘无束的自我表达的粉丝。
Radical honesty, radical self-expression.
彻底的诚实，彻底的自我表达。
Like I have to say, this is- But he can't handle it back to him, but he wants to be able to dole it out.
就像我不得不说的，这是——但他无法将其返还给他，但他希望能够将其分发出去。
That's the other thing.
那是另一回事。
That's off in the case.
在这种情况下就这样了。
That is off in the case.
在这种情况下这是关闭的。
Yeah.
是的。
Whereas I think Ted is trying not to do- Ted gets pushed in points and he does engage in that.
虽然我认为特德试图不这样做——特德被推了分，但他确实参与了这一点。
Like there's a bunch of moments you could map out in the series where Ted like- can't take it anymore.
就像你可以在这个系列中规划出很多泰德喜欢的时刻——不能再忍受了。
And he finally says the thing he shouldn't have said.
他终于说出了不该说的话。
You know, and it's like, oh, fudge.
你知道，这就像，哦，胡说八道。
Like, you know, there's these moments, right?
就像，你知道，有这样的时刻，对吗？
But I think like, even at the beginning when he tries to be like, oh, no, that was with my sister.
但我想，即使在一开始，当他试图表现得像，哦，不，那是和我妹妹在一起的时候。
Like he's really trying to protect Robin.
就好像他真的想保护罗宾一样。
He's trying to protect.
他正在努力保护。
Yeah, he knows it's gonna be triggering.
是的，他知道这会被触发。
That whole sequence of sister is really funny.
姐姐的整个过程真的很有趣。
You play in that grade.
你在那个年级打球。
It's a good 10 episode.
10集挺好看的
10 has a lot of funny moments in this one.
10 这其中有很多有趣的时刻。
Well, getting, my favorite was, and we'll talk about this, but getting.
好吧，获得，我最喜欢的是，我们将讨论这个，但是获得。
Belvedevo.
贝尔韦杰沃。
No. Old ref though.
不，虽然是老裁判。
Belvedevo is an old ref because Jordana didn't know what that was.
贝尔维德沃是一位老裁判，因为乔丹娜不知道那是什么。
Old tackle.
老钓具。
But Jordana didn't know what Belvedevo is.
但乔丹娜并不知道贝尔维德沃是什么。
We're so old.
我们都这么老了
But at that joke, you were, you killed that joke.
但在那个笑话中，你是，你扼杀了那个笑话。
I just want to say that was a great Belvedevo call.
我只想说贝尔韦德沃的电话很棒。
Even they don't know what this meant.
就连他们自己也不知道这意味着什么。
That was like a laugh out loud.
那就像大声笑出来。
I watched it twice that loud.
我看了两遍，声音那么大。
I went back to watch it loud twice.
我回去大声看了两遍。
While we're here, while we're here, why don't we just talk about that moment?
当我们在这里，当我们在这里，我们为什么不谈论那一刻呢？
Okay, Jay, that is a- Butterfuca.
好吧，杰伊，那是——黄油。
The Butterfuca pants that Marshall parades in.
马歇尔游行时穿着的 Butterfuca 裤子。
And another, it's Oracle of Delphi.
另一个是德尔福的甲骨文。
They're trying to get- It's another one of them.
他们正试图得到——这是他们中的另一个人。
They're trying to- It's the thing.
他们正试图——这就是问题所在。
They're like, we have to put it to the group and take it to the group.
他们就像，我们必须把它放到小组中并将其带到小组中。
There's something about, there's five of them.
有事，有五个。
So there's always a tiebreaker.
所以总有一个决胜局。
Like there's a, you know, it's a good number for that, for the high model.
就像有一个，你知道，对于高级型号来说，这是一个很好的数字。
Yeah, they're a conveniently odd number, yeah.
是的，它们是一个方便的奇数，是的。
Marshall is doing one thing.
马歇尔正在做一件事。
But Jason Segal, when we shot that, I remember it was like he walked out, and I think we rehearsed it obviously without the pants because we weren't in costume yet.
但是杰森·西格尔，当我们拍摄时，我记得他就像走出去一样，我想我们排练时显然没有穿裤子，因为我们还没有穿戏服。
But he walked out and I just, I will never forget, Jason Siegel walking out and kind of, he was like clucking his head like a chicken, like kind of his chin was going back and forth and he kept going, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh.
但他走了出去，我永远不会忘记，贾森·西格尔走了出去，他就像一只小鸡一样咯咯地叫着他的头，就像他的下巴来回摆动，然后他继续走，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃。
And he knew that we were dying.
他知道我们快要死了。
He knew that we were dying, even Neil was dying Neil was the least breaky of all of us.
他知道我们快要死了，甚至尼尔也快死了，尼尔是我们所有人中最不崩溃的一个。
Me, Ali, and Kobe were gone, like gone, gone, gone.
我、阿里和科比都消失了，消失了，消失了，消失了。
And I was shocked at how quick the pop was and how we looked like you couldn't, like Sue Fetterman and Pam must have, you guys must have had a search for a serious face.
我对流行音乐的速度如此之快以及我们看起来像你不能的样子感到震惊，就像苏·费特曼和帕姆一定有的那样，你们一定在寻找一张严肃的面孔。
I bet we found the frames you weren't breaking.
我打赌我们找到了你没有破坏的框架。
We found the five frames you weren't breaking.
我们找到了你没有破坏的五个框架。
It was one of those where Pam had to be like, guys, professional acting, please, please, Because he would, and you know, when Siegel or Neil knew that they were making you laugh, it wasn't like they were trying to help you get through the scene.
这是其中之一，帕姆必须像，伙计们，专业表演，拜托，拜托，因为他会的，你知道，当西格尔或尼尔知道他们让你发笑时，他们并不是想帮助你度过这个场景。
They were trying to crush you, they wanted you to, and the way that Jason paraded these pants around, and he, and he, when he knew that we were losing it, he just amped it up to 11, you know, it was just like, it made me laugh so much.
他们试图压垮你，他们希望你这么做，杰森炫耀这些裤子的方式，他，他，当他知道我们正在失去它时，他只是把它提高到 11，你知道，这就像，这让我笑得很开心。
I watched that whole scene over twice and he was when he was like, when he was going like Ted.
我把整个场景看了两遍，他当时就像特德一样。
Ted.
特德.
He's like, he's like, come on.
他就像，他就像，来吧。
You got me.
你抓住了我。
You got that back here.
你已经把它带回来了。
And even Ted can't go.
就连特德也不能去。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
But I'm telling you, we probably we had to do like eight takes of this very quick.
但我告诉你，我们可能必须很快完成八次拍摄。
But normally that should have been three takes tops.
但正常情况下应该是三拍上衣。
Yeah.
是的。
It was just such a one off little thing.
这只是一件一次性的小事。
But I remember that as one of the other one was, I remember because I was trying to get to burning man, you guys were trying to get me out so I could go burning man.
但我记得，就像另一个人一样，我记得因为我试图去燃烧的人，你们试图把我救出来，这样我就可以去燃烧的人。
I think second or third season.
我觉得还有第二季或者第三季
But what was the one where Lily walks in, oh, it was the intervention episode, where she walks in with a Cockney accent.
但是莉莉走进来的那一集，哦，是干预集，她带着伦敦口音走进来。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
And we had never rehearsed it.
我们从来没有排练过。
We just did it, because I think maybe it was a rewrite that it was a Cockney accent.
我们只是这样做了，因为我认为这可能是重写为伦敦口音。
And Ally walks in with that Cockney accent, and we lost our minds.
艾莉带着伦敦腔口音走进来，我们失去了理智。
Lost your shit.
失去了你的狗屎。
And I was like, this is the funniest thing I've ever seen, and I have to catch a plane.
我当时想，这是我见过的最有趣的事情，我必须赶飞机。
Like, I have to go.
就像，我得走了。
I am fucking myself over by laughing this lecture.
这次讲座我笑死了。
So there are a couple moments when you, I mean, I think people like hearing about this moments where we just lost our minds on set laughing.
所以，有一些时刻，我的意思是，我认为人们喜欢听到我们在片场大笑时失去理智的时刻。
Yeah, it's not like that was happening all the time.
是的，这种情况并不总是发生。
It had to be something truly out of the ordinary, like the Buttafooko pants.
它必须是真正与众不同的东西，比如 Buttafooko 裤子。
And by the way, that must have been old ref too.
顺便说一句，那肯定也是老裁判了。
I'm sure I don't know, Jordana, did she?
我确定我不知道，乔丹娜，是吗？
Did you recognize them?
你认出他们了吗？
Buttafooko was like, that is a deep cut 1990s, like embarrassing Long Island story.
Buttafooko 说，这是一个深刻的 20 世纪 90 年代，就像令人尴尬的长岛故事。
But if you lived through the 90s, it's no explanation needed.
但如果你经历过90年代，那就不需要解释了。
Yeah.
是的。
It was in Coby's thing of like, I don't want you to get shot in the face, right?
就像科比那样，我不想让你脸上中弹，对吧？
It was so jarring, it was just right.
真是太刺耳了，又恰到好处。
That's what that story was.
那个故事就是这样的。
Yeah, oh yeah, being from Long Island in the 90s was tough because everyone's like, ah, the butterfly story from Long Island.
是的，哦，是的，90 年代来自长岛很艰难，因为每个人都喜欢，啊，长岛的蝴蝶故事。
Let's talk about that.
我们来谈谈这个吧。
I'm like, no, please, I don't want to represent that.
我想，不，拜托，我不想代表这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
But that was when I watched it, I was like, oh, this is the butterfly pants.
但当我看到它的时候，我就想，哦，这是蝴蝶裤。
Like this is where that was.
就像这就是原来的地方。
And it's a very strong memory of us just being the least professional actor.
这是我们作为最不专业的演员的强烈记忆。
Like we could not keep it together.
就像我们无法将它保持在一起一样。
And Jason was not helping us at all.
杰森根本没有帮助我们。
This was a weird week.
这是奇怪的一周。
Cause you had that and then you had guys licking your face.
因为你有这样的经历，然后有人舔你的脸。
Yeah.
是的。
There's a lot of weird stuff.
有很多奇怪的东西。
Neil's dressed in a 10 man robot outfit and saying the word moist over and over again.
尼尔穿着十人机器人服装，一遍又一遍地说着“潮湿”这个词。
It was a weird, it was a genuinely like fever dream of an episode in some ways.
这很奇怪，从某些方面来说，这真的就像是一场狂热的梦想。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you know what my biggest laugh was actually?
你知道我最大的笑声是什么吗？
What?
什么？
Jordana pointed it out or I would have missed it.
乔丹娜指出了这一点，否则我就会错过它。
You never say it.
你从来不说。
but it's just over the corner of the pro, the name of the play.
但就在职业选手的拐角处，这出戏的名字。
Suck it, Lily, suck it, Lily.
吸吮它，莉莉，吸吮它，莉莉。
That he, I was called Suck it, Lily.
他，我被称为吸它，莉莉。
Me too, I lost my mind at that.
我也是，我当时就失去了理智。
I had completely forgotten about it.
我完全忘记了这件事。
Like to the point where I was like, did I not, did props do that without us asking them to?
就像我想的那样，我不是吗，道具是在没有我们要求的情况下就这样做的吗？
And I never noticed it.
我从来没有注意到它。
It was so funny to me, and also I had a genuine question.
这对我来说很有趣，而且我也有一个真正的问题。
So funny.
太有趣了。
Who are the other people coming to see this play?
还有哪些人来看这部剧？
I said the same thing, Drew Becca, I was like, how, especially Neil's play.
我也说了同样的话，德鲁·贝卡，我想，怎么样，尤其是尼尔的比赛。
No, that's what I meant, Neil's play.
不，这就是我的意思，尼尔的表演。
I could understand friends and family come to the other play, but who is coming to see Suck It Lily by Barney Stinson?
我可以理解朋友和家人来看另一出戏，但谁会来看巴尼·斯廷森的《Suck It Lily》呢？
And then walking out, as if like, this isn't as great as I expected it to be.
然后走出去，好像这并不像我想象的那么好。
The times review wildly inflated how good this was.
《泰晤士报》的评论疯狂地夸大了这有多好。
I said the same, like, who are these people?
我也说了同样的话，这些人是谁？
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And also, it was the same venue and the same.
而且，这是同一个地点，同样的。
the same exact venue, the same crew, who was on our crew.
同样的场地，同样的工作人员，就是我们的工作人员。
It was on our crew.
这是我们的船员。
Yeah, that was the second Lily thing.
是的，这是莉莉的第二件事。
I was like, that was just where it's called though for me.
我当时想，这正是我所需要的。
I was like, whoa, I completely forgot about that play.
我当时想，哇，我完全忘记了那场比赛。
Such a funny, like, if you catch that, it's so funny.
太有趣了，如果你听到了，那就太有趣了。
Ooh, really good, really funny.
哦哦，真的很好，真的很有趣。
But I almost felt like, did I never notice that, which is insane to say.
但我几乎觉得，我从来没有注意到这一点，这说起来很疯狂。
But that's how much I forgot that.
但我就是这么忘记的。
Well, I think you had to have because the way Pam shot it, it was like.
好吧，我认为你必须这么做，因为帕姆拍摄的方式就像。
We probably wrote it.
可能是我们写的。
But it could like the way the person was arching and holding up the program was clearly so you could see it It's almost like a Simpsons joke.
但它可能就像那个人拱起并举起程序的方式很明显，这样你就可以看到它，这几乎就像辛普森一家的笑话。
It was such a quick visual throw a plan or something.
这是一个如此快速的视觉抛出计划或其他东西。
Yeah, or an airplane exactly And I love that you didn't hit like you didn't we never called it out We never called out that that was the show's but also like Lily was probably handed a program That said suck it Lily and she just like moves on with it Yeah, it's something great up There was something great about not calling it out at all, and it's just there for you to find.
是的，或者是一架飞机，我喜欢你没有像你那样撞到我们从来没有喊出来我们从来没有喊出那是节目的但也像莉莉可能被递给一个程序说吸它莉莉，她只是喜欢继续它是的，这是一件很棒的事情根本不喊出来有一些很棒的东西，它就在那里等你找到。
And it's the same thing as the slap bed at the end.
而且和最后的巴掌床是一样的。
It's like, it's there, even if you have no idea what the slap bed even is, it's you're like, all right, well, he just wanted to slap the shit out of him.
就好像，它就在那里，即使你根本不知道巴掌床是什么，你也会觉得，好吧，好吧，他只是想把他打得屁滚尿流。
That's two wouldn't make any sense, but the slapping the shit out of Barney made enough sense.
那两个没有任何意义，但是把巴尼打得屁滚尿流就足够了。
There's something nice about the under explanation, something like that.
下面的解释有一些很好的东西，类似的东西。
There's something nice about just leave it, let it speak for itself.
留下它，让它自己说话是有好处的。
Yeah, you know what really made me laugh?
是的，你知道是什么让我发笑吗？
And I loved playing it, was like in Lily's play how Ted gets roped in to being, was he capitalism?
我喜欢玩它，就像在莉莉的戏剧中，泰德是如何被束缚的，他是资本主义吗？
What was he greed, capitalism?
他的贪婪是什么，资本主义？
He was capitalism, I think, or maybe he's creepfucker.
我认为他是资本主义，或者也许他是个混蛋。
But I love what Marshall says.
但我喜欢马歇尔所说的。
Oh my God, tits in this place.
天哪，奶子在这个地方。
Yeah, he's so excited.
是的，他太兴奋了。
And then he's really jealous later.
后来他真的很嫉妒。
I never get chosen to be in this.
我从来没有被选中参与其中。
And it's funny because it's almost like a small payoff.
这很有趣，因为这几乎就像是一个小小的回报。
And we didn't, again, we didn't call it out.
我们没有，再一次，我们没有大声疾呼。
Maybe it would have been nice call it out.
也许把它说出来会很好。
At the very end, Marshall is part of the show.
最后，马歇尔成为了演出的一部分。
He's part of the show.
他是节目的一部分。
When he slaps the shit out of the party, he's part of that show.
当他把派对打得一团糟时，他就是这场表演的一部分。
He's the day of sex.
他是性爱之日。
He's in his head.
他在脑子里。
He's the day of sex slopina.
他是性爱的一天。
Is the day is like slapping a see when shit like that comes up.
当这样的事情出现时，这一天就像打耳光一样。
It's like when Elliot coin the phrase, Tegendary, I just want to get in a time machine.
就像艾略特创造了“Tegendary，我只想坐上时光机”这个词一样。
I want Deus Ex slapping out to be on the show.
我希望《杀出重围》能够出现在节目中。
I guess this is the next best thing when these things come up on the podcast, but it does break my heart a little bit because Deus Ex slapping a is fucking brilliant job.
我想当这些事情出现在播客上时，这是下一个最好的事情，但这确实让我有点心碎，因为杀出重围打耳光真是太棒了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And now, you know, there's also one of my greatest fears is being roped into audience participation while I'm like at a player concert.
现在，你知道，我最大的恐惧之一就是当我像在一场球员音乐会上时，被束缚在观众的参与中。
I want zero eyes on me if I'm in the audience.
如果我在观众席上，我希望零的目光注视着我。
Okay, well, question for you, let's do the symposium.
好吧，好吧，问你一个问题，我们来开个研讨会吧。
You're a wonderful actor.
你是一个很棒的演员。
You're a wonderful theater actor.
你是一位出色的戏剧演员。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And a sidebar, if anybody out here has the chance to see Josh on stage live a fantastic and different theater actor than you are TV.
还有一个侧边栏，如果有人有机会在舞台上看到乔什，他是一位与电视上不同的出色的戏剧演员。
Like you really, there's different superpowers you on both.
就像你一样，你两者都有不同的超能力。
Okay, as you've gotten to plenty of shows, sometimes they're terrible.
好吧，既然你看过很多演出，有时它们很糟糕。
What do you say to the friend in the show?
你想对剧中的朋友说什么？
Are you ever, are you ever flirting with that honesty level?
你曾经、你曾经以那种诚实程度调情过吗？
Or you were great, but the show sucked.
或者你很棒，但演出很糟糕。
You ever tried to like, shoot, like, parse it out?
你曾经尝试过喜欢、拍摄、喜欢、解析它吗？
My friend, Dion Flynn, who's like, he's a writer for The Tonight Show, and he is one of my dearest friends.
我的朋友迪昂·弗林（Dion Flynn）是《今夜秀》的编剧，也是我最亲爱的朋友之一。
We have a two decade old running bit, 25 year running bit, about what you say to a friend who's show you hated when you go back to.
我们有一个长达 20 年、25 年的连续报道，内容是关于你对一位朋友说的话，当你回去时，他表现出你的憎恨。
Well, that's, here we are, we're in this episode.
嗯，那就是，我们在这里，我们在这一集中。
One of his lines is, you were never better, which is like really confusing.
他的台词之一是，你从来没有更好过，这真的很令人困惑。
Yeah, I feel like it'd be a zer.
是的，我觉得这会是一个泽。
You know, you were up there, man.
你知道，你就在那里，伙计。
Like, I forget he has so many good ones.
就像，我忘记了他有这么多好东西。
He's actually compiled the list of all of ours.
他实际上已经编制了我们所有人的名单。
But it is, I think it's a bit of like actors who a lot of times, especially when you're younger, the audience is mostly actors, they're your friends, who are coming to see your show.
但我认为这有点像演员，很多时候，尤其是当你年轻的时候，观众主要是演员，他们是你的朋友，会来看你的表演。
So you have to kind of like, sometimes you're bold away.
所以你必须有点喜欢，有时你会大胆离开。
Like, I remember going to see Chris Messina in a show.
就像，我记得在一场演出中看到克里斯·梅西纳。
he invited me to a show that he was in off-Broadway with at the flea.
他邀请我去看他在外百老汇举办的跳蚤演出。
I remember that play.
我记得那场戏。
I just, I was like Chris, this is, like it was one of those performances I was like, I couldn't give that performance.
我只是，我就像克里斯一样，就像这是我喜欢的表演之一，我无法表演。
It was so daring and scary and incredible, incredible.
这是如此大胆、可怕、令人难以置信、难以置信。
But yeah, it's a lot of actors who are, do you know the joke of how many actors does it take to screw in a light bulb?
但是，是的，有很多演员，你知道需要多少演员才能拧紧一个灯泡的笑话吗？
How many?
多少？
100, one to screw in the light bulb, 99 to sit in the audience with complimentary tickets and say how they could have done it better.
100 美元，其中一名负责拧紧灯泡，99 美元则拿着免费门票坐在观众席上，并说出他们如何可以做得更好。
That's it.
就是这样。
I mean, it's, my wife is a dancer, choreographer.
我的意思是，我的妻子是一名舞蹈家、编舞家。
So we've gone and seen a lot of like very funky, very downtown, tiny little performances.
所以我们去看了很多非常时髦、非常市中心的小型表演。
And sometimes they're genuinely not that far off from Barney and the Robot costume or Lily's thing.
有时它们确实与巴尼和机器人服装或莉莉的服装相差不远。
They're sometimes super crazy and we can go be, we can be celebrate, we can be there to support a certain performer and think they were amazing.
他们有时非常疯狂，我们可以去疯狂，我们可以庆祝，我们可以在那里支持某个表演者并认为他们很棒。
They moved their movement was amazing.
他们的动作令人惊叹。
They were great, but the show as a whole was didn't grab us, we didn't like the show, but we thought they were great.
他们很棒，但整个节目并没有吸引我们，我们不喜欢这个节目，但我们认为他们很棒。
But even that, when you try to drive, you almost can't say that either, because somebody coming off stage doesn't want to hear about how the show sucked, but they were great, because maybe they needed to believe the show was great, to give that amazing performance.
但即便如此，当你尝试开车时，你也几乎不能这么说，因为从舞台上下来的人不想听到演出如何糟糕，但他们很棒，因为也许他们需要相信演出很棒，才能呈现出令人惊叹的表演。
It's just weirding, because you want to believe you were part of something, and all your efforts was, well, it came to something, and that people had a good experience.
这很奇怪，因为你想要相信你是某件事的一部分，而你所有的努力都是，嗯，它达到了某件事，并且人们有很好的体验。
One of the worst things you can say to an actor after a play, and this is just a public service announcement, congratulations is a terrible thing to say.
演出结束后你可以对演员说的最糟糕的事情之一，这只是一个公共服务公告，恭喜是一件可怕的事情。
You know they hated it when they say that.
你知道他们讨厌这样说。
Yeah, when they say congratulations, it's like, they're not, this was not something they.
是的，当他们说祝贺时，就好像，他们不是，这不是他们的事。
Yeah, you were in that.
是的，你也在其中。
You were in that.
你当时就在其中。
You were up there.
你当时就在上面。
That existed and you were there.
那是存在的，而你也在那里。
I believe when you were on stage, I believed you were there.
我相信当你在舞台上时，我就相信你就在那里。
Um, yeah, um, I will say years ago, a college friend of mine, Beth Schachter, we were at a play.
嗯，是的，嗯，我会说几年前，我的一位大学朋友贝丝·沙赫特 (Beth Schachter)，我们一起去看一场演出。
It was like an evening of one acts that were, um, it was all absurdist.
这就像一个晚上的表演，嗯，这一切都是荒谬的。
It was kind of like, it was, it was like tin foil, Nanae's cover, you know, people.
有点像，它是，就像锡箔，七苗的封面，你知道的，人们。
It was very strange.
这很奇怪。
And my friend, who I went to college with, she directed me a lot in plays in college.
和我一起上大学的朋友在大学里给我指导了很多戏剧。
She leaned over to me in the middle of it.
她在中间向我倾身。
And she said, this is the kind of theater our parents fear were making.
她说，这就是我们父母担心的那种戏剧。
That's a great line.
这是一条很棒的线。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
而这个老人，他必须让我爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告，广告结束，回到演出。
It's so hard because when you're in something, it's almost like you can badmouthe your own family.
这太难了，因为当你陷入困境时，你几乎可以说自己家人的坏话。
But when somebody else badmouts your family, you're like, wait a second.
但当其他人诽谤你的家人时，你会想，等一下。
Like, if I have work on something and somebody goes, I remember even writing for Dave Letterman, which was a great honor.
就像，如果我在做某件事而有人离开，我记得甚至为戴夫·莱特曼写作，这是一种莫大的荣幸。
I think Dave's a legend.
我认为戴夫是一个传奇人物。
I love Dave.
我爱戴夫。
Every now and again, I tell someone that and they'd go, oh, I hate him.
我时不时地告诉别人这一点，他们会说，哦，我恨他。
And I go, well, I don't know what to say to that.
我走了，好吧，我不知道该说什么。
I write stuff for that show and I love that and I would take it personally that they were dissing Dave, most people love Dave by the way, but it's just weird, it's like I'm not Dave, I didn't create that show, I was just a writer, I was 22 year old writer but I would take it personally and it's like you wanna, it's so hard because you have to believe in the thing you're doing so it's always that dance of like, can I slightly indicate I didn't like the show but I thought the person was amazing in the show and I think it's always, you just can't say it.
我为那个节目写了一些东西，我喜欢这个，我个人认为他们在贬低戴夫，顺便说一句，大多数人都喜欢戴夫，但这很奇怪，就像我不是戴夫，我没有创作那个节目，我只是一个作家，我是22岁的作家，但我会个人认为，就像你想要的那样，这太难了，因为你必须相信你正在做的事情，所以它总是那样的舞蹈，我可以吗？稍微表明我不喜欢这个节目，但我认为这个人在节目中很棒，我认为它总是如此，你只是不能说出来。
And I'm of the feeling that like, especially if someone is a professional or has their eyes set on that.
我有这样的感觉，特别是如果有人是专业人士或关注这一点的话。
Like, you know, I never would tell someone like, maybe you should consider doing something else.
就像，你知道，我永远不会告诉别人，也许你应该考虑做点别的事情。
Like, that's something, if that comes about, that's gonna be, you know, there's a famous Ed Norton story that he went in and auditioned.
就像，如果真的发生了，那就是，你知道，有一个著名的埃德诺顿故事，他进去试镜了。
I'll say who it was, it's George Ann Walken, who was this casting director for years.
我会说是谁，是乔治·安·沃肯，他担任选角导演多年。
I don't know if she still does.
我不知道她现在是否还这样。
But I think he was auditioning for the public something he'd been at it for a while.
但我认为他正在为公众试镜，他已经这样做了一段时间了。
And he's told the story many times, but he auditioned and she said, look, I think you're really smart.
这个故事他已经讲过很多次了，但他试镜时她说，看，我认为你真的很聪明。
I like you a lot.
我很喜欢你。
I think you need to start looking at something else to do.
我认为你需要开始寻找其他事情做。
And like a week later, he booked Primal Fear and he became a movie star and got an Academy where so there's always a thing of like, we don't know what's bad.
大约一周后，他预订了《原始恐惧》，成为了一名电影明星，并获得了一个学院，所以总是有这样的事情，我们不知道什么是坏事。
Nobody knows anything is the rule.
没有人知道任何事情都是规则。
And also like, you're an actor, you're an artist, like some things are gonna hit, some things aren't.
而且就像，你是一名演员，你是一名艺术家，就像有些东西会受欢迎，有些东西不会。
I think that it's better to keep the enthusiasm up of like, I love you, man, I'm here to support you.
我认为最好保持热情，比如，我爱你，伙计，我在这里支持你。
I want you to, you know, to do well.
我希望你，你知道，做得很好。
There's a great story.
有一个很棒的故事。
I think it was John Krasinski told about that he kind of dissed a movie, either to Paul Thomas Anderson or near Paul Thomas Anderson and Paul Thomas Anderson pulled him aside and he was like, never criticized movies.
我认为约翰·卡拉辛斯基告诉他，他对一部电影很不满意，无论是对保罗·托马斯·安德森还是在保罗·托马斯·安德森附近，保罗·托马斯·安德森把他拉到一边，他就像从不批评电影。
Like, especially, you know, in public.
就像，特别是，你知道，在公共场合。
He said, even bad movies, people are trying to make something good and interesting.
他说，即使是糟糕的电影，人们也在努力制作一些好的、有趣的东西。
People were so hard.
人们太难了。
You got to follow the person's lead.
你必须听从那个人的引导。
If someone comes off stage and goes, didn't that show suck?
如果有人下台走了，那节目不是很糟糕吗？
You can go like, well, you were great, but yeah, maybe, if the person comes off and doesn't offer that up, just you got to be like, go with God.
你可以说，好吧，你很棒，但是，是的，也许，如果这个人不提供这些，你就必须说，与上帝同行。
And there's probably a couple of people in your life that you should keep on tap, who are like, you'll give it to your straight.
在你的生活中，可能有一些人是你应该保持联系的，他们就像是，你会把它交给你的直人。
like you're my honesty people.
就像你们是我的诚实人一样。
But for the most part, I think like, you know, I mean, this was, this was stacked up for maximum, you know, this, we're getting into a more serious discussion about something that this episode actually doesn't exactly interrogate because Lily's play clearly sucked.
但在大多数情况下，我认为，你知道，我的意思是，这是，这是最大程度的堆积，你知道，这个，我们正在就这一集实际上并没有完全审问的事情进行更严肃的讨论，因为莉莉的表演显然很糟糕。
Barney's play intentionally sucked.
巴尼的表现故意很糟糕。
But I liked that Barney got a little sucked in.
但我喜欢巴尼有点被吸引。
He actually cared about his performance and he's like, I, it's too many guys didn't get to see the end of it.
他实际上很关心自己的表现，他说，我，太多人没能看到结局。
He like clearly wants to be able to finish his show, which I think I liked that moment, because that's the, even he wants to finish his stupid show, because goddamn it, he's come this far.
他显然希望能够完成他的表演，我想我喜欢那一刻，因为那就是，即使他也想完成他的愚蠢表演，因为该死的，他已经走了这么远。
I liked that we showed that side.
我喜欢我们展现出这一面。
And also, there's something about Barney that became clear.
而且，关于巴尼的一些事情也变得清晰起来。
It's like, this is an aspect of his gambling addiction, which is that he has to win.
就好像，这是他赌博成瘾的一个方面，那就是他必须赢。
He has to win.
他必须赢。
It's like they don't put money on it, but the bet is I can make you tell me this sucks, Lily.
就好像他们不花钱，但我打赌我可以让你告诉我这很糟糕，莉莉。
Yeah, yeah, and he will not stop.
是的，是的，他不会停止。
Yeah, it is, it is his gambling addiction.
是啊，就是他的赌瘾。
He must win, that's really true, and he has to, but then he, I love that there's a little part of him that kind of loves his own show.
他必须赢，这是真的，他必须赢，但是他，我喜欢他身上有一小部分喜欢他自己的表演。
Yeah.
是的。
And then he gets slapped in the face by Marshall, so he gets his come up and it's like that.
然后他被马歇尔打了一巴掌，所以他就上来了，事情就是这样。
And there is no clearer review than slapping the face of a person performing.
没有比打表演者的脸更清晰的评价了。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I love that Marshall ended that end of the show for Barney.
是的，我喜欢马歇尔为巴尼结束了演出。
I love that Ted gets pulled up for the curtain call, I love that he has to show.
我喜欢泰德在谢幕时被拉起来，我喜欢他必须表现出来。
There was something that is fun to play about like, I am, I don't want this to be happening, but I have to act like it's all okay.
有些事情很有趣，比如，我是，我不希望这种情况发生，但我必须表现得好像一切都好。
Like, whenever you get to opposing things that kind of pull you apart, you know, that's always really fun to play.
就像，每当你遇到使你们分裂的对立事物时，你知道，玩起来总是很有趣。
When you have to wear a mask, you know, yes, yeah, totally, totally.
当你必须戴口罩时，你知道，是的，是的，完全，完全。
And that's what the whole episode's about, which I love.
这就是整集的主题，我很喜欢。
And I think it's a good, it's a good Ted and Robin episode.
我认为这是一部很好的《泰德和罗宾》剧集。
It kind of, it both moves their future forward a little bit and raises the stakes and they're going to live together now, which is a huge part of the episodes to come, but also shows you like a little bit of trouble, right?
就这样，这既让他们的未来向前迈进了一点，也提高了赌注，他们现在要住在一起，这是接下来的情节的重要组成部分，但也表明你喜欢一点麻烦，对吧？
There's a little bit of trouble rooming there, right?
那里的房间有点麻烦，对吧？
It's definitely without spoilering anything.
这绝对不会剧透任何东西。
It foreshadows things to come at the end of the season.
它预示着赛季结束时将会发生的事情。
I got to highlight a great needle drop.
我必须强调一下伟大的针落。
I did not get into the stooges.
我没有陷入傀儡之中。
I was not into the stooges at this moment in my life.
在我生命中的这个时刻，我不喜欢傀儡。
Carter and I love the stooges.
卡特和我都喜欢傀儡。
One of the best shows I've ever seen is Rebecca Carter and I went to see Iggy Pop at Irving Plaza in the 90s.
我看过的最好的演出之一是丽贝卡·卡特 (Rebecca Carter)，上世纪 90 年代我去欧文广场 (Irving Plaza) 看了伊基·波普 (Iggy Pop)。
And he was at that point, you know, what it was in his 50s or whatever he was.
他当时就在 50 多岁的时候，或者无论他是什么时候。
And he gave the most fucking energetic punk rock show, you know, 25 years after, you know, when he would have been considered in his prime of that.
他举办了一场最他妈充满活力的朋克摇滚表演，你知道，25 年后，你知道，当时他被认为正处于巅峰时期。
He is so raw.
他太原始了。
And that is like one of my favorite, um, Stooges songs, Reiki Pop songs.
这就像我最喜欢的一首，嗯，傀儡歌曲，灵气流行歌曲。
I want to be your dog.
我想成为你的狗。
And the idea I got was so proud of it watching it last night with her back.
我的想法是为昨晚和她一起观看而感到非常自豪。
I said, no other CBS sitcom ever used a Stooges song.
我说过，没有其他 CBS 情景喜剧使用过 Stooges 的歌曲。
That's It's essentially a song about like kind of S&M.
这本质上是一首关于 S&M 的歌曲。
Yeah.
是的。
It basically is one that song.
基本上就是那首歌。
So it's like a five o'clock.
所以现在就像五点钟。
Also one cool thing about that song is like, you know how the hi-hat in drumming, like the hi-hat kind of keeps the tempo?
这首歌还有一件很酷的事情是，你知道鼓中的踩镲是如何保持节奏的吗？
In that song, if you listen to that song, the hi-hat part is a single piano note.
在那首歌中，如果你听那首歌，踩镲部分是一个钢琴音符。
There's just one piano note going ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
只有一个钢琴音符：叮、叮、叮、叮、叮。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
It's kind of like basically the hi-hat part, but it's as if the drummer is keeping time on one piano key, the ding, ding, ding.
这基本上有点像踩镲部分，但就好像鼓手在一个钢琴键上计时，叮、叮、叮。
I love that about that song.
我喜欢那首歌。
It's such a weird production choice.
这是一个非常奇怪的制作选择。
I don't know if David Bowie, God, I should know that.
我不知道大卫·鲍伊，上帝，我是否应该知道这一点。
I don't know if David Bowie produced it out or not, but it's just a really cool.
我不知道大卫·鲍伊是否制作过它，但这真的很酷。
Listen for that one piano note, and I want to be your dog, but- David Bowie produced Iggy Pops.
听听那个钢琴音符，我想成为你的狗，但是——大卫·鲍伊制作了伊基·波普斯。
He didn't do stooges.
他没有做傀儡。
He did Iggy Pops, I think solo.
我想他是单独表演《Iggy Pops》的。
He did Iggy solo, I think.
我想他是单独表演伊基的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
But there's also something funny, like when you literalize it, when it's like, I want to be your dog, and then you see Robin walking five men with collars and leashes.
但也有一些有趣的事情，就像当你把它字面化时，当它就像，我想成为你的狗，然后你看到罗宾带着项圈和皮带遛着五个人。
It takes the entendre away.
它把参与者带走了。
It makes it a single entendre song.
它使它成为一首单一的歌曲。
It's no longer about what it's- Something else is barely a double entendre in the song, but we still made it even less.
这不再是关于它是什么——歌曲中的其他东西几乎不是双关语，但我们仍然把它做得更少。
Yeah.
是的。
It was a great great music choice Great needle drop.
这是一个很棒的音乐选择，很棒的落针。
I have really forgot that we did that and that should be on the list of like fucking cool music we put on like the stooges were on at 830 on CBS after King of Queens and before two and a half men and like a CSI.
我真的忘记了我们这么做了，这应该出现在我们播放的酷炫音乐列表中，就像哥伦比亚广播公司在《King of Queens》之后和《两个半男人》之前播放的走狗一样，就像《CSI》一样。
Hey, did you ever read um this is a great book recommendation for anyone who's kind of interested in in the the punk scene in the 70s.
嘿，你读过吗？对于任何对 70 年代朋克场景感兴趣的人来说，这是一本很棒的书推荐。
Have you read Please Kill Me?
你读过《请杀了我》吗？
I can't, Carton, Carter and I recommended to you because we read it like in our 20s that though.
我不能，卡顿、卡特和我推荐给你，因为我们在 20 多岁的时候就读过它。
Oh no, I didn't read it until like maybe eight or 10 years ago.
哦不，我大概是八、十年前才读到的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Cause that's we, Carter turned me out of that book and then we would tell everybody about it.
因为那就是我们，卡特让我不再读那本书，然后我们会把这件事告诉每个人。
I don't know if you ever just, I love that book so much.
我不知道你是否曾经说过，我非常喜欢那本书。
It's this great oral history, punk.
这是一段伟大的口述历史，朋克。
Yeah, strong.
是的，很强。
That book's incredible.
那本书太不可思议了。
It's an oral history.
这是一段口述历史。
It starts basically with Velvet Underground.
它基本上是从地下丝绒开始的。
It ends with sex pistols.
它以性手枪结束。
Yeah, it sort of takes you through the whole chap, the whole movement.
是的，它会带你经历整个章节、整个动作。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's a great, starting at like Max's Kansas City, going to CBGB's, Patti Smith.
但这是一个很棒的事情，从麦克斯的堪萨斯城开始，到 CBGB 的帕蒂·史密斯。
Like it takes you through, it's almost like a great history of 70s New York, but told through the very specific lens of punk.
就像它带你穿越一样，它几乎就像一部 70 年代纽约的伟大历史，但通过非常具体的朋克镜头来讲述。
Absolutely, the Ramones.
绝对是雷蒙斯乐队。
The Ramones, yeah.
雷蒙斯乐队，是的。
Another great book that my friend Lizzie Goodman wrote is called Meet Me in the Bathroom.
我的朋友莉齐·古德曼写的另一本好书是《在浴室里见我》。
Did you read that book?
你读过那本书吗？
No, I didn't.
不，我没有。
It's kind of a spiritual secret.
这是一种精神上的秘密。
to please kill me because it starts in 2001 to 2011, New York City starting with the strokes, through Vampire Weekend, LCD Sound System, DFA record, that whole thing.
请杀了我，因为它始于 2001 年至 2011 年，纽约市从笔画开始，通过吸血鬼周末、液晶音响系统、DFA 唱片，整个事情。
Like everyone thought like this isn't a scene, but she actually showed that there was something, you know, the yeah, yeah, yeah, as in TV on the radio, like there was so much going on in the moment.
就像每个人都认为这不是一个场景，但她实际上表明有一些东西，你知道，是的，是的，是的，就像广播中的电视一样，就像此刻发生了很多事情。
So anyway, two great oral history books about New York City.
无论如何，这是两本关于纽约市的伟大口述历史书。
Please kill me as the 70s.
请杀掉我这个70后。
me in the bathroom by Lizzy Goodman, 2001, 2011.
《我在浴室》丽兹·古德曼 (Lizzy Goodman)，2001 年、2011 年。
I love a good oral history.
我喜欢好的口述历史。
It's a great way to tell a story.
这是讲故事的好方法。
I know, it's a great, and it's like so readable because it's these little quotes and back and forth.
我知道，它很棒，而且它非常具有可读性，因为它是这些小引号和来回的。
I actually thought about, when I wrote my novel, my novel is like all these switching forward perspectives.
我其实想过，当我写小说的时候，我的小说就像所有这些向前视角的切换。
And I thought about the obsessive readability of a book like Please Kill Me because you just need to keep turning the page because it's all these fascinating people.
我想到了像《请杀了我》这样的书的可读性，因为你只需要不断翻页，因为里面都是这些迷人的人。
You're like, well, I can't stop here.
你就像，好吧，我不能停在这里。
Iggy pops about to talk on the next page.
伊吉突然在下一页上讲话。
And after that, David Bowie says something and then Joey Ramone, it's so, it's great.
之后，大卫·鲍伊说了些什么，然后乔伊·雷蒙说，太棒了。
It's like, it's a great like a bathroom read.
就像，这就像浴室读物一样很棒。
So you're gonna read as much or as a little.
所以你要读或多或少的书。
Davey Jones in the Six is written as a kind of like fake oral history about a made up band.
六人乐队中的戴维琼斯被写成一种关于一支虚构乐队的虚假口述历史。
Oh, is it?
哦，是吗？
I didn't.
我没有。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's a great way to tell a story.
但这是讲故事的好方法。
And, but yeah, so we've gone far afield.
但是，是的，所以我们已经走得很远了。
We've talked about the Stooges in Terminator 2 in this episode called Stuff.
我们在这一集“Stuff”中讨论了《终结者 2》中的傀儡。
At least it's all cool.
至少一切都很酷。
You know what, the episode's called Stuff and we're just talking about a lot of stuff.
你知道吗，这一集叫做“Stuff”，我们只是在谈论很多东西。
We're just talking about stuff.
我们只是在谈论事情。
Before we go, I could just report in this directly from Kobe Smolders.
在我们离开之前，我可以直接从科比·斯莫尔德斯那里报告这一点。
My guess is because there's no sound, we were just told where to go physically and made up the words.
我的猜测是因为没有声音，我们只是被告知要去哪里并编造单词。
So she also doesn't quite remember her.
所以她也不太记得她了。
Did you just text her in real time about that question?
你刚刚实时给她发短信询问了这个问题吗？
Not only did I text her, but she didn't remember it at all.
我不仅给她发了短信，而且她根本不记得了。
And I videoed the show now on Hulu on my side.
我现在在 Hulu 上录制了这个节目。
Good to be honest.
说实话很好。
I sent her the clip, and that is the report that we just got it.
我把剪辑发给她，这就是我们刚刚收到的报告。
Well, produced, my God.
好吧，生产出来了，我的天。
All right, so you guys were just making shit up?
好吧，所以你们只是在胡编乱造？
I think there it is.
我想就是这样。
I think doing your own play.
我觉得还是自己演戏吧。
You're on shitty play.
你这是在玩烂戏。
A shitty play within the show about a shitty play.
节目中的一部关于一部烂剧的烂剧。
You're doing your own half-baked play.
你正在做你自己的半生不熟的戏。
But it probably wasn't shitty.
但它可能并不糟糕。
It sounds like it was good.
听起来好像不错。
It was kind of good.
这很好。
And I think it was kind of like, who needs writers?
我认为这有点像，谁需要作家？
I think that was the feeling.
我想这就是感觉。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Like who needs writers?
就像谁需要作家一样？
We can just- There's a great- This is brutal.
我们可以——有一个伟大的——这太残酷了。
Comp to that, during sandcastles in the sand where she is arguing where Kobe, and I believe Alan's sick.
相比之下，在沙子里的沙堡里，她在争论科比在哪里，我相信艾伦病了。
Yeah, as her dad.
是的，就像她爸爸一样。
Arguing over something.
为某事争论。
And it was another silent argument.
这又是一场无声的争论。
it was a music video and it was filled with the end hysterical.
这是一部音乐录影带，结尾充满了歇斯底里的感觉。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
So we, in this episode, stuff, episode 16 of season two of How I Make Mother, in our talk, Craig and I, we mentioned the movie Splash, the great Ron Howard, Tom Hanks, Derek, Hannah, comedy, we mentioned Terminator 2.
所以，在《我如何做母亲》第二季第 16 集中，克雷格和我的谈话中，我们提到了电影《水花》、伟大的朗·霍华德、汤姆·汉克斯、德里克、汉娜、喜剧，我们提到了《终结者 2》。
And as we go through this, we're talking a lot about references that you and Carter and the writers were pulling from.
当我们讨论这个问题时，我们谈论了很多你和卡特以及编剧们引用的参考资料。
I remember when you told me, I think after I got in cast, that you thought of Ted as a mix of Lloyd Dobler from Say Anything Meets George Bailey from It's a Wonderful Life.
我记得当你告诉我时，我想在我加入演员阵容后，你认为泰德是《说任何话》中的劳埃德·多布勒与《生活多美好》中的乔治·贝利的混合体。
Was that the mashup?
那是混搭吗？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
That's the mashup.
这就是混搭。
I think about it every year when I watch It's Wonderful Life, which I just did the other day with my kids.
每年当我观看《生活多美好》时，我都会想起这个问题，前几天我刚刚和孩子们一起看这部电影。
My kids hadn't seen that.
我的孩子们没有看到这一点。
And I'm like, George Bailey, there's so much George Bailey and 10 minutes.
我说，乔治·贝利，乔治·贝利太多了，还有 10 分钟。
Yeah, well, also Christmas story.
是的，还有圣诞故事。
I mean, we're, as artists, I think we're the, some of our references on some level, you know?
我的意思是，作为艺术家，我认为我们在某种程度上是我们的一些参考，你知道吗？
And I think as a writer, I know this, and I even did this as an actor a little bit.
我认为作为一名作家，我知道这一点，甚至作为一名演员我也这样做过一点。
You imitate your heroes until your own voice and style comes through.
你模仿你的英雄，直到你自己的声音和风格出现。
You know, you, I tried to write like Philip Roth or Kenny Lonergan or, you know, like, I was trying to write like these people.
你知道，你，我试图像菲利普·罗斯或肯尼·洛纳根那样写作，或者，你知道，我试图像这些人一样写作。
And then I get my own voice and same with you guys.
然后我就得到了自己的声音，和你们一样。
And you know, this is airing I think in February, but we're a couple, we're a little bit ahead.
你知道，我想这个节目会在二月份播出，但我们是一对，我们有点领先。
And my friend and my, someone we both, that meant so much to us artistically died, very tragically, Rob Reiner and his wife Michelle, a couple of days ago from when we were recording this.
我的朋友和我的朋友，我们俩，对我们来说在艺术上意义重大的人，罗布·莱纳和他的妻子米歇尔，非常悲惨地去世了，就在我们录制这段视频的几天前。
And I just wanted to kind of just have a couple of words about what his movies meant to both of us, just personally, and I just posted something on Instagram about this, but Rob cast me in a pilot for NBC called Everyday Life in 2003 or four, I can't remember, and the pilot was never picked up, but he directed it, he played my dad, Mercedes, who played my mom, it's about a family of therapists all live and work in the same brownstone.
我只是想简单谈谈他的电影对我们俩的意义，就我个人而言，我刚刚在 Instagram 上发布了一些相关内容，但罗布在 2003 年或四年前让我出演了 NBC 的一部名为《日常生活》的试播集，我记不清了，试播集一直没有被接拍，但他导演了这部片子，他扮演了我的父亲梅赛德斯，谁扮演了我的妈妈，这是关于一个家庭治疗师的故事，他们都在同一个上流社会生活和工作。
And it was all improvised and it was really wild and really fun.
这一切都是即兴创作的，非常狂野，非常有趣。
And I got to know Rob and we had lunch over the years many times and he screened a cut of my second movie at his house with his wife and they gave me such beautiful feedback on it.
我认识了罗布，多年来我们多次共进午餐，他和他的妻子在他家里放映了我的第二部电影的剪辑，他们给了我非常好的反馈。
And he was just a lovely, generous, passionate, beautiful man.
他是一个可爱、慷慨、热情、美丽的男人。
And he also made some of the greatest films ever.
他还制作了一些有史以来最伟大的电影。
I mean, truly like Pantheon films, you know, stand by me.
我的意思是，真的像万神殿电影一样，你知道，支持我。
This is Spinal Tap, the Princess Bride, when Harry Met Sally, Misery, a few good men.
这是《脊椎泰普》，《公主新娘》，当哈利遇到莎莉、米塞里和几个好男人时。
Like, you can't believe that one director directed all of this.
就像，你无法相信一位导演导演了这一切。
It's astonishing.
真是令人惊讶。
It's an astonishing achievement.
这是一个令人惊讶的成就。
Who else could do that?
还有谁能做到这一点？
I don't know any of it.
我什么都不知道。
It's the range of it.
这是它的范围。
And it was in the span of a few years.
而且这只是几年的时间。
Like he had a run that is just among the all time creative runs in the history of film.
就像他的一次奔跑只是电影史上最富有创意的奔跑之一。
I mean, it stands next to any other body.
我的意思是，它站在任何其他身体旁边。
So what creative DNA do you think is Reiner-esque that found its way into how I met your mother?
那么你认为莱纳式的创意 DNA 融入到了我与你母亲的邂逅中？
I think you can make an argument that how I met your mother is essentially when Harry Metzali meets, stand by me meets the Princess Bride.
我想你可以说我是如何遇见你母亲的，本质上就是哈利·梅扎利遇见了，站在我身边遇见了公主新娘。
Because when Harry Metzali is the gold standard New York romantic comedy, right?
因为当哈利·梅扎利成为纽约浪漫喜剧的黄金标准时，对吗？
I mean, there's just like, it's just untouchable.
我的意思是，就像，它是不可触碰的。
And even within that movie, there is the framework of it's a story kind of being told.
即使在那部电影中，也有一个讲述故事的框架。
All those couples you see, interspersed with, obviously Nora Afran wrote it beautifully, but I know she developed that whole project with Rob so collaboratively.
你看到的所有那些情侣，显然诺拉·阿夫兰（Nora Afran）写得很漂亮，但我知道她和罗布（Rob）如此合作地开发了整个项目。
And then in like the Princess Bride, that idea of a story being told and popping in and out of the story, a story being told to a child by an older, wiser person and pop jumping in and out of the story, if you put that together with when Harry Met Sally, that's basically how I met your mother and stand by me having again that future narrator kind of making sense of, in that case, childhood, but remembering this beautiful chapter of his life that he's trying to capture as an adult in his middle age, who's played beautifully by Richard Dreyfus in the movie, God damn, that's how your mother all of those things are how much mother and then like the musical comedy piece like when Carter and I would write those Robin Sparkle songs what I would always look to was this is Spinal Tap because the songs that they did for the Spinal Tap they wrote them to be good songs.
然后就像《公主新娘》一样，一个故事被讲述，然后在故事中突然出现，一个由一个年长、更聪明的人给一个孩子讲的故事，然后在故事中跳进跳出，如果你把它和《哈利遇到莎莉》放在一起，这基本上就是我遇见你母亲的方式，并再次支持我，让未来的叙述者有点理解，在这种情况下，童年，但记住他生命中这一美丽的篇章，他在成年后试图捕捉到这一章理查德·德雷福斯 (Richard Dreyfus) 在电影《天杀的，这就是你的母亲》中扮演的非常漂亮的年龄，这就是你母亲的样子，所有这些事情都是多么母亲，然后喜欢音乐喜剧片，就像卡特和我写那些罗宾·斯帕克尔的歌一样，我一直关注的是《Spinal Tap》，因为他们为《Spinal Tap》写的歌曲都是好歌。
Those are really really good songs.
这些都是非常非常好的歌曲。
They were so deadpan about what that movie was that they said the songs will be absurd but we're also going to make them great and there's something about, Reiner is like just control of tone, even within these incredibly diverse projects that he just knows what these things are, talk about these other DNA, like the DNA of those things, every molecule of those movies knows what movie they're in.
他们对那部电影的内容如此面无表情，以至于他们说这些歌曲会很荒谬，但我们也会让它们变得很棒，而且有一些东西，莱纳就像是对音调的控制，即使在这些令人难以置信的多样化项目中，他也知道这些东西是什么，谈论这些其他的DNA，就像那些东西的DNA一样，这些电影的每个分子都知道它们在哪部电影中。
And that is coming through the singular vision of Ralph Reiner.
这是通过拉尔夫·雷纳 (Ralph Reiner) 的独特愿景实现的。
I loved him.
我爱他。
I love his work.
我喜欢他的工作。
I never got to meet him.
我一直没能见到他。
I feel like I lost a friend and I never even met the man.
我觉得我失去了一个朋友，而我什至从未见过这个人。
And boy, his influence on everything and how much mother included is just beyond measure, he's just a brilliant man.
男孩，他对一切的影响以及母亲的影响是无法估量的，他是一个才华横溢的人。
Yeah, and I think also if you could distill or boil down what is a director's job, it's to make sure everyone's in the same movie that there's a kind of...
是的，我认为如果你可以提炼或归结什么是导演的工作，那就是确保每个人都在同一部电影中，有一种......
I read this thing that Tarantino, he made a movie actually before Reservoir Dogs that no one saw.
我读到塔伦蒂诺的这件事，他实际上在《落水狗》之前拍了一部没有人看过的电影。
And he said, I made all my mistakes on that movie.
他说，我在那部电影中犯了所有的错误。
I got all my mistakes out.
我把我所有的错误都改掉了。
Like I figured out, what do I think?
就像我想的那样，我怎么想？
I never knew that.
我从来不知道这一点。
And he said to someone early on, like, I don't know what a light has seen.
他很早就对某人说过，我不知道光看到了什么。
I don't know how to frame a shot.
我不知道如何构图。
And they said, yeah, as an photographer does that, you just have to keep the story in mind and make sure that everything that's showing up on screen is in service to your vision of the story.
他们说，是的，作为一名摄影师，你只需牢记故事，并确保屏幕上显示的所有内容都服务于你对故事的看法。
And I think Rob was an absolute master at, like you said, because you stack those all up against each other.
我认为罗布绝对是这方面的大师，就像你说的，因为你把这些都放在一起对比。
You could probably isolate certain themes that recur.
您或许可以隔离某些重复出现的主题。
You know, I mean, there is a notion of like true love, love wins the day, you know, the value in both friendship and also, and also seeing how friendship and how love evolves over time.
你知道，我的意思是，有一种像真爱一样的观念，爱情获胜，你知道，友谊和爱情的价值，以及友谊和爱情如何随着时间的推移而演变。
When Harry Met Sally is astonishing the economy of storytelling, it almost could be a nine-year run of watching Harry and Sally find their way to each other, but he does it in two hours.
《当哈利遇见莎莉》的故事讲述成本惊人，几乎要花九年的时间看着哈利和莎莉找到彼此，但他只用了两个小时就完成了。
There's no fat on it.
上面没有脂肪。
It's just like, it's incredibly efficiently done.
就像，它完成得非常高效。
Yeah, and that's part of his brilliance.
是的，这就是他的才华的一部分。
It's just knowing what the story needs and not going past that, not never losing sight of that.
只是知道故事需要什么，而不是超越它，而不是永远忽视它。
I know Carter, too, is just an enormous, enormous fan.
我知道卡特也是一个超级超级粉丝。
And when we pitched the pilot, when we pitched Time With The Mother as a series, I guarantee you every time we pitched it, we referenced the Princess Bride and the future, and essentially Peter Fogg telling the story.
当我们推销试播集时，当我们推销《与母亲在一起的时光》系列时，我向你们保证，每次我们推销它时，我们都会提到公主新娘和未来，本质上是彼得·福格讲述的故事。
I like, and when Harry Metzali, this is how we pitched the show.
我喜欢，当 Harry Metzali 时，这就是我们推销节目的方式。
We pitched the show using Rob, And also the Princess Bride tells this kind of mythic fairy tale, but also narrator's head is pitching a kind of mythic fairy tale about his 20s and 30s in New York.
我们用罗伯来推销这个节目，《公主新娘》讲述了这种神话童话，而且叙述者的脑袋也在推销一种关于他20多岁和30多岁在纽约的神话童话。
And Stan by me has that feeling too, like it's a fable, it's his writer's life, but it's how we all write our memories, right?
我身边的斯坦也有这种感觉，就像这是一个寓言，这是他作家的生活，但这就是我们所有人书写记忆的方式，对吗？
We keep writing and refining our memories.
我们不断书写并完善我们的记忆。
And I think he had, you know, you can see this from his dedication to politics, to free speech like he was an incredibly passionate man who also believed like we could be better.
我认为他，你知道，你可以从他对政治和言论自由的奉献中看到这一点，就像他是一个非常热情的人，也相信我们可以做得更好。
Yes.
是的。
You know, there was something in his movies that was aspirational in the best sense of the word.
你知道，他的电影中有一些东西是最好意义上的渴望的东西。
I felt like even though you could definitely glean a through line of deep optimism, it was a hard-earned optimism, my favorite kind.
我觉得尽管你绝对可以收集到一系列深刻的乐观情绪，但这是一种来之不易的乐观情绪，是我最喜欢的一种。
It was a realist's optimism, but it was definitely like there were headed someplace better.
这是一种现实主义者的乐观态度，但肯定会朝着更好的方向发展。
Yes.
是的。
Let's leave our characters better than we found them.
让我们让我们的角色比我们发现时更好。
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Let's let's evolve.
让我们一起进化吧。
Let's grow.
让我们成长吧。
And he was a curious kind of searching mind and heart that man.
他是一个具有好奇心和探索精神的人。
It was so clear in his life and his work that we was.
他的生活和工作中的这一点与我们一样清晰。
I didn't know that I didn't remember, I guess, that you acted in that pilot with him.
我不知道我不记得你和他一起演过那部试播集。
He played my dad.
他扮演我的父亲。
I forgot that.
我忘记了。
I knew it was sort of him and he directed it.
我知道这是他干的，也是他导演的。
I forgot you acted in scenes with him.
我忘了你和他一起演过戏。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
Yeah, of course.
是的，当然。
It was the season right before how I made mothers that it was just the pilot.
那是在我让母亲们知道这只是试播集之前的一季。
Just the pilot didn't get picked up by NBC.
只是试播集没有被 NBC 报道。
But you got to act in scenes with with Rob Reiner who was also directing it.
但你必须和罗伯·莱纳一起演戏，他也是这部电影的导演。
That's an incredible experience, man.
这是一次令人难以置信的经历，伙计。
And I told this story in my Instagram post, but I'll just tell it to you now, but he was kind of behind the monitor and I was kind of lurking and talking to him a little bit.
我在 Instagram 帖子中讲述了这个故事，但我现在就告诉你，但他在监视器后面，而我则潜伏着并与他交谈了一会儿。
And he turned to me and he said, I'm nervous.
他转向我说，我很紧张。
And I said, you still get nervous?
我说，你还紧张吗？
I thought like, why is he nervous for this pilot?
我想，为什么他对这位飞行员感到紧张？
Have you seen?
你见过吗？
And he said, if you're not nervous on the first day of shooting, it's time to leave the business, you know?
他说，如果你第一天拍摄不紧张，就该离开这个行业了，知道吗？
Like nerves to him were a real sign.
对他来说，紧张是一个真实的迹象。
You still cared so much.
你还是那么在乎。
He still has seen it in the game and it was, his heart was in it.
他仍然在比赛中看到了这一点，而且他的心也在其中。
His heart was in everything he did, including that.
他所做的一切都是他的心，包括那件事。
It clings so deep into his career.
它深深地融入了他的职业生涯。
He still was in it.
他仍然身在其中。
I love that story and that says everything.
我喜欢这个故事，它说明了一切。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
He just loved making things and he was a great collaborator and he was, he was truly, he offered himself as a mentor to me in a lot of ways.
他只是喜欢创造东西，他是一位出色的合作者，他确实在很多方面都成为了我的导师。
You know, we, for a couple of years there, we were having lunch once a year or so And he was, you know, often with his producer, producing partner, Alan Greisman is a great guy who also produced that show.
你知道，我们在那里的几年里，我们每年大约吃一次午餐，你知道，他经常和他的制片人、制作伙伴一起吃午饭，艾伦·格雷斯曼是一个很棒的人，他也制作了那个节目。
And they were just really kind to me.
他们对我真的很好。
And I'll never forget him inviting me over to the house to screen the cut of liberal arts.
我永远不会忘记他邀请我去家里放映文科剪辑。
And he cast me in that pilot when I was, I don't know, 28, 29, 27, maybe, I don't know.
当我，我不知道，28岁、29岁、27岁，也许，我不知道的时候，他让我出演那个试播集。
But I was a couple of years out of grad school.
但我已经毕业几年了。
I think I had been on Broadway in the graduate and I'd gotten fired from my first pilot.
我想我毕业时曾在百老汇演出，但我被我的第一个飞行员解雇了。
The second series didn't work.
第二个系列没有成功。
The third pilot season, I tested like 10 times and didn't get anything.
第三个试播季，我测试了大约10次，但什么也没得到。
And so this was like my fourth pilot season, maybe fifth pilot season.
这就像我的第四个试播季，也许是第五个试播季。
And I don't know, just to be able to like, there are these moments, like maybe you felt this way about Letterman, Craig, but where, when you tell your parents who cast you or what you're doing, they get it.
我不知道，只是为了能够喜欢，有这些时刻，就像你可能对莱特曼、克雷格有这样的感觉，但是当你告诉你的父母是谁选了你或者你在做什么时，他们就会明白。
Like your parents in Long Island, your parents in Ohio, they get it.
就像你在长岛的父母、你在俄亥俄州的父母一样，他们明白这一点。
Like my parents grew up watching all in the, you know, they watched all in the family.
就像我的父母从小就看着一切，你知道，他们看着家里的一切。
They watched and loved all those movies.
他们观看并喜爱所有这些电影。
So when I got to say Rob Reiner cast me in a pilot for NBC, they also knew what NBC was, there was something that that we, it was important moment for me.
所以当我说 Rob Reiner 让我出演 NBC 的试播集时，他们也知道 NBC 是什么，我们有一些东西，这对我来说是重要的时刻。
It's important, I know what you mean.
这很重要，我知道你的意思。
It's important.
这很重要。
I have a real job.
我有一份真正的工作。
I'm really doing this because this person believes in me.
我这样做真的是因为这个人相信我。
Yeah, and I remember I shot the pilot and my grandfather died before I got the news.
是的，我记得我射杀了飞行员，在我得知消息之前我的祖父就去世了。
I actually got the news.
我确实得到了消息。
It wasn't picked up the day of my grandfather's funeral, but my dad said something really kind of sweet.
我祖父葬礼那天没有收到，但我父亲说了一些非常甜蜜的话。
He said, well, your grandpa went to his death thinking you were doing a show for NBC with Rob Reiner, like, that's okay, that's okay.
他说，好吧，你爷爷去世时还以为你在和 Rob Reiner 一起为 NBC 做节目，就像，没关系，没关系。
That was good for him to feel into that.
能够感受到这一点对他来说是件好事。
And it was just like, there are these moments, maybe we've talked about this, but there are these moments as an artist, as a young actor or writer where you lose faith in yourself.
就像，有些时刻，也许我们已经讨论过这一点，但作为一名艺术家、一名年轻演员或作家，有些时刻你会对自己失去信心。
it's natural.
这是自然的。
Is this going to happen for me?
这会发生在我身上吗？
Oh, it's happening for that guy.
哦，这件事发生在那个人身上。
Why isn't it happening for me or her?
为什么这不会发生在我或她身上？
And then there are these people that come along and say, hey, we need you.
然后有些人走过来说，嘿，我们需要你。
We'd like you.
我们想要你。
You're the guy.
你就是那个家伙。
You're the one for this.
你就是这个人。
And Rob came along at a moment that I needed someone to believe in me, like him.
当我需要有人像他一样相信我时，罗布出现了。
I needed Rob Reiner.
我需要罗布·莱纳。
It was great that it was actually Rob Reiner.
很高兴这实际上是罗布·莱纳。
I got the actual guy to say, and I remember auditioning for him.
我有一个真正的人要说，我记得为他试镜。
and I remember making him laugh.
我记得让他笑了。
I remember there was a great, funny comedian actress who played my wife, Mary Gallagher, and we were improvising at the, I think at the network, like it was our network test, and he was kind of interviewing us, and maybe he was playing the couples therapist essentially, like we were in couples therapy.
我记得有一位伟大、有趣的喜剧女演员扮演我的妻子玛丽·加拉格尔，我们在网络上即兴创作，就像我们的网络测试一样，他在采访我们，也许他本质上是在扮演夫妻治疗师，就像我们在夫妻治疗中一样。
And she was like, I don't wanna do anything crazy fancy for the wedding, you know?
她说，我不想为婚礼做任何疯狂的事情，你知道吗？
And she wanted this like kind of hippie wedding.
她想要一场类似嬉皮士的婚礼。
And I was like, my mom, my parents are not gonna, like, and they're like, well, where do you want to get married?
我当时想，我的妈妈，我的父母不会，他们会说，好吧，你想在哪里结婚？
And I was like, Chippurianis, which is like the most fancy place you could get married in New York City.
我当时想，Chippurianis，这是纽约市最高档的结婚地点。
Like, it's like, you know, it's absurd how aristocratic it is.
就像，就像，你知道，它是多么的贵族化，这是荒谬的。
But I knew, I knew Chippurianis because I think like an ex girlfriend's friend had gotten married there.
但我知道，我认识奇普里亚尼斯，因为我觉得就像前女友的朋友在那里结婚了一样。
But Rob knew Chippurianis and he almost fell out of his seat, you know, it was like the perfect thing.
但罗布认识奇普里亚尼斯，他差点从座位上摔下来，你知道，这就像是一件完美的事情。
I think it got me the job that I knew.
我认为它让我得到了我所熟悉的工作。
I can't imagine the satisfaction of knowing you made a murder.
我无法想象知道你犯了谋杀罪后的满足感。
Yeah.
是的。
Like really laugh.
真的很喜欢笑。
Like what?
比如什么？
That's, that's, you'll always have that moment.
就是这样，就是这样，你永远都会有那一刻。
Yeah.
是的。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
And he was also, he was also, um, you know, some funny people don't laugh.
他也是，他也是，嗯，你知道，一些有趣的人不会笑。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Oh, he was a funny person who laughed.
哦，他是一个爱笑的有趣的人。
So you fell.
于是你就摔倒了。
I know.
我知道。
He's so well.
他很好。
He felt his work and felt his generosity.
他感受到了他的工作，感受到了他的慷慨。
I also felt him wanting us to do well.
我也感觉到他希望我们表现出色。
We were clearly the ones he want.
我们显然是他想要的人。
I think we were there.
我想我们就在那里。
We were the only ones who tested.
我们是唯一进行测试的人。
Like he wanted it to be us.
就像他希望是我们一样。
us.
我们。
He created an environment where we could do our best work.
他创造了一个让我们可以尽最大努力工作的环境。
So, you know, it's also, it's a strange thing.
所以，你知道，这也是一件奇怪的事情。
I made this thing with him.
我和他一起做了这件事。
We worked together for a couple weeks.
我们一起工作了几个星期。
No one ended up seeing it except some NBC executives who said we're going to pass on this.
除了一些 NBC 高管表示我们将转达这一消息外，最终没有人看到它。
So it's not like I have this big document of like, this is what we made together.
所以我没有这么大的文件，这是我们一起制作的。
I think I saw one cut of it or something and it was like, I'm just moved on and then I did how I met your mother in the next year.
我想我看到了其中的一个片段或其他东西，就像，我只是继续前进，然后我做了第二年遇见你母亲的事情。
But yeah, I am forever grateful that he, he said, he pointed and said, you, I'm I'm grateful I got to spend some time with him.
但是，是的，我永远感激他，他说，他指着说，你，我很感激我能和他一起度过一些时间。
I'm grateful for those lunches and I'm grateful that those movies live on and inspired us and inspired people even that didn't know him.
我很感激这些午餐，我很感激这些电影一直存在，激励着我们，激励着那些不认识他的人。
Yeah, but you know, I can attest just personally that he was just a wonderful dude and he was a great talent and he was also a real mench and I miss him.
是的，但是你知道，我个人可以证明他是一个很棒的人，他是一个伟大的天才，他也是一个真正的男人，我想念他。
And I'm so, it's so heartbreaking that he was denied the happy ending that he gave so many of his characters and so.
我是如此，这太令人心碎了，他给了这么多角色的美好结局却被剥夺了。
Yeah, that's a lot of love for you, Rob, and Michelle, and just wishing his family and his loved ones the best.
是的，罗布和米歇尔，这对你们来说是很大的爱，祝愿他的家人和他所爱的人一切顺利。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matata。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer aka Gen Z Master is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人又名 Gen Z Master 是 Emily Blumberg。
artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购 Craig Thomas 的处女作《That's Not How It Happened》、《Wherever Books Are Sold》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, This shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。